Do you have something to say? A story that
needs to be told? A cause that needs to be
heard? A local issue that needs to go global?
YouTube and the World Economic Forum are opening
the doors of Davos to an individual, a big
thinker, a campaigner. You. To share the stage
with world leaders in a special panel Dedicated
to your cause. Are you fighting for human
rights? The environment? Poverty? Whatever
your cause, this is your chance to stand up
and get your voice heard. Only one person
can join them. Someone with passion. With
energy. With an urgent cause that needs the
world's attention. Press record, deliver your
pitch, upload it to YouTube by Jan 4th 2010
for your chance to participate in the Davos
Debates. Visit youtube.com/davos for more
details. If you had the chance to re-design
your world, what would it look like?